IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
A FLURRY OF ACTIVITY COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON, D.C.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
MITCH MCCONNELL PUTTING TOGETHER
A PLAN TO AVERT A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN AFTER DEMOCRATS REFUSED
TO BUDGE ON FUNDING A BORDER
WALL.
ALSO PRESIDENT TRUMP SCORING A
BIG WIN OVER THE SENATE
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSES A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM BILL.
HE'S READY TO SIGN IT INTO
OFFICE, INTO LAW ONCE IT MOST OF
THE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECLARING
VICTORY INTERNATIONALLY AGAINST
ISIS AND SYRIA IN A TWEET.
ANNOUNCING THE 2,000 AMERICAN
TROOPS WILL BE WITHDRAWING VERY
SOON.
ALL OF THIS HAPPENING AS
DEMOCRATS PREPARE AN ONSLAUGHT
OF INVESTIGATIONS INTO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
DANA, I WILL START WITH YOU.
THIS FEELS LIKE A MUDDY MOMENT.
>> Dana: THE END OF THE YEAR
GETTING ANYTHING DONE TYPE OF
THING.
>> Pete: YOU HAVE THE
TRANSITION OF POWER.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING HE WANTS A
WALL.
HE'S GOING TO SHUT IT DOWN IF HE
DOESN'T GET IT.
NOW WE ARE SEEING A CR INTO
FEBRUARY.
PRISON REFORM BILL PASSES BUT
OVERWHELMINGLY BIPARTISAN.
THEN THIS DECLARATION THAT WE
DEFEATED ISIS.
TIME TO LEAVE SYRIA.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHERE
THAT CAME FROM AND HOW QUICKLY
WILL HAPPEN.
>> Dana: I WILL TAKE THEM ONE
BY ONE.
I THINK THERE IS SOME LOGIC TO
THEM.
>> Greg: I PREFER THAT YOU
DON'T AND DO IT ALL AT ONCE.
>> Dana: ONE BIG PARAGRAPH.
NO COMMAS.
I WILL GIVE IT A SHOT.
ON WALL FUNDING, I THINK IT'S A
NOD TO REALITY.
IT WAS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO
DO THIS WITHOUT HAVING TO SHUT
DOWN.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
WANT THAT DISTRACTION OVER THE
NEXT TWO WEEKS.
IT WASN'T GOING TO BE POSSIBLE
TO GET THE 5 BILLION.
THINK THEY REALIZED THAT WERE
GOING TO HAVE TO HAVE THIS FIGHT
ANOTHER TIME.
ASK REALITY.
>> Pete: WHY DO YOU WANT TO
HAVE IT WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ARE
IN CHARGE?
>> Dana: THEY WEREN'T GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT NOW.
HE GAVE THE DIRECTION TO THE
AGENCIES.
LET ME KNOW WHAT MONEY YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE.
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO REPROGRAM
IT.
CONGRESS IS SAYING IF YOU CAN'T
DO THAT.
YOU CAN ARGUE IT ROUND OR YOU
CAN ARGUE IT FLAT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT SAYING
THEY ARE NOT FOR ANY BORDER
SECURITY.
THEY WOULD BE FOR BORDER
THEY JUST DON'T WANT HIM TO CALL
AT THE WALL.
IT'S JUST SEMANTICS.
>> Pete: A FENCE IS MORAL BUT
A WALL ISN'T?
>> Dana: ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, IT'S A BIG WIN FOR HIM.
SOMETIMES REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS
CAN GET THINGS DONE THAT
DEMOCRATS CAN'T.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WAS STALLED
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IT COULDN'T GET THROUGH THE
REPUBLICAN SENATE, BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT HIS SHOULDER
BEHIND IT.
SO DID JARED KUSHNER.
GIVING A HAND TO THE DEMOCRATS
IS THAT WE WANT TO WORK WITH
HIM.
IT'S THAT IMPORTANT.
SOMETIMES ISSUES TAKE SO LONG TO
WORK THEIR WAY THROUGH.
THE PUBLIC HAS TO COME ALONG.
IT TAKES A WHILE TO DO THAT.
THIS IS A BIG WIN AND IT WILL
HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE.
ON ISIS, I THINK THAT ONE IS
CERTAINLY THE PRESIDENT'S
PREROGATIVE.
IT DOES SEEM CURIOUS.
I HOPE HE'S RIGHT.
>> Pete: I THINK WE ALL HOPE
HE'S RIGHT.
ISIS HAS BEEN DECIMATED BUT IF
YOU WERE NOT THERE, IRAN STILL
IS.
TURKEY STILL IS.
RUSSIA STILL IS.
>> Jedidiah: DON'T YOU THINK
IT'S INTERESTING HE'S PULLING
OUT THIS LIBERTARIAN MUSCLE WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
EVERYONE WAS SAYING THAT
REFLECTS THAT THE IT'S THE
LIBERTARIAN WING OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
YOU TALK ABOUT SYRIA,
WITHDRAWING TROOPS.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT SIDE OF HIM.
IT'S A SIGN HE CAMPAIGNED
HEAVILY ON.
WHEN HE WAS CAMPAIGNING, HEARING
THEM TALK ABOUT HIS INVOLVEMENT
IN THE POTENTIAL WAR.
I HAVE A STRONG LIBERTARIAN
STREAK THAT ATTRACTED ME TO HIM.
I WONDER IF THAT PART OF THE
PARTY, THE RAND PAULS, MIKE
LEEs PUT SOME PRESSURE ON HIM
TO NOT GO SO HAWKISH AND GET
SOME THINGS DONE THEY FEEL WILL
APPEAL TO THEM AND INDEPENDENT
VOTERS, YOUNGER VOTERS THAT HE
LOOKS FORWARD TO HIS NEXT RUN,
HE'S GOING TO NEED A LOT OF
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE WHO
MIGHT BE ATTRACTED TO POLICIES
LIKE THAT.
>> Pete: IT WILL BE A NICE
THING FOR HIM TO BE ABLE TO SAY
IN 2020.
WE PASSED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
I'M THE PRESIDENT FOR EVERYBODY,
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN IN
PRISON TOO.
THEY HAD SENSES THAT DIDN'T FIT
THE CRIME.
IS IT A WIN FOR THE PRESIDENT?
>> Juan: YEAH, FROM WHAT WE
HEAR, JARED KUSHNER HAS BEEN THE
GUY HAS PUT HIMSELF OUT THERE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL AS IF
THEY'VE BEEN TALKING, THEY ARE
JUST DUMPED BY THE PRESENCE OF
JEFF SESSIONS AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO REFUSED TO
MOVE ON, THEN MITCH MCCONNELL
WHO WOULDN'T CALL A VOTE.
MITCH MCCONNELL CHANGED HIS MIND
AND WENT ALONG.
BUT THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE HAD BEEN IN FAVOR OF
THIS ALL ALONG.
IN THAT SENSE YOU COULD SAY IT'S
A WIN FOR THE PRESIDENT.
PUTIN FOR LIKE DEMOCRATS ARE
FINDING A GROOVE WE TALK ABOUT
INVESTIGATIONS.
IS THAT WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE KNOWN FOR IN 2019?
ARE THEY GOING TO FOCUS ON ANY
LEGISLATION?
THE LIST OF INVESTIGATIONS.
TAX RETURNS, TAX ORGANIZATIONS,
BUSINESS INTEREST, RYAN ZINKE,
MEMBERS OF THE CABINET.
ELIJAH, AND SENT 51 LETTER TO
THE WHITE HOUSE DEMANDED BY THE
MIDDLE OF JANUARY THERE'S
ANSWERS TO THE STUFF.
WHAT WILL DEFINE DEMOCRATS?
>> Juan: I THINK WILL BE ALL
ABOUT TRYING TO GET SOMETHING
DONE.
THIS WILL BE PART OF IT.
SO MUCH OF EVERYTHING WE TALK
ABOUT HIS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
RIGHT NOW HIS TROUBLES ARE
MOUNTING AND THE CLOSING OF HIS
FOUNDATION HERE.
SO MUCH OF IT IS EVERYTHING
TRUMP'S NEWS.
I THINK WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
ESPECIALLY FROM NANCY PELOSI AND
HOUSE LEADERSHIP IS AN EMPHASIS
ON SHOWING VOTERS THAT GUESS
WHAT, OUR PARTY IS ABLE TO
SUCCEED AND TO REACH SOLUTIONS,
GET THINGS DONE FOR YOU.
FOR INSTANCE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THIS WALL, PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
MEXICO IS GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
THAT'S WHAT HE CAMPAIGNED ON.
THEN HE SAID THE MILITARY WILL
BUILD IT, RIGHT?
AND THEN HE SAID NO, I WILL FIND
THE MONEY.
OBVIOUSLY IT WAS NEVER GOING TO
GET DONE.
>> Pete: I DON'T THINK THAT
WAS OBVIOUS.
I THINK YOU'RE POINTING OUT SOME
FAIR MOMENTS WHERE IT'S BEEN
HEDGED UPON.
>> Juan: I WILL SAY ON SYRIA,
I'M STUNNED.
IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE WE'VE
FLIPPED IDENTITIES.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE ONES,
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND OTHERS,
SAYING THIS IS A HUGE OBAMA-LIKE
MISTAKE.
>> Dana: AT LEAST THEY ARE
CONSISTENT.
>> Juan: BUT THEN YOU HEAR,
TED LIEU, THE CONGRESSMAN FROM
CALIFORNIA, ROBERT FORD WHO WAS
OBAMA'S FIRST AMBASSADOR TO
SYRIA SAYING THAT THE U.S. HAS
NO NATIONAL INTEREST.
I THINK IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THE
IRANIANS ON THE RUSSIANS
CONTINUE TO PROP UP
BASHAR AL-ASSAD AND REMEMBER
TRUMP GOING AFTER THE REDLINE
AND ALL OF THAT.
WE STILL HAVE TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN AND ELSEWHERE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S
DOING.
>> Pete: HE RAN ON WE'VE BEEN
NATION-BUILDING IN THE
MIDDLE EAST FOR TOO LONG.
IT'S TIME TO COME HOME.
THE QUESTION IS, WHO FEELS THAT
VACUUM.
GREG, I'M GOING TO GO TO YOU.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
I WAS READY TO GO GET A GLASS OF
WATER.
>> Pete: DID HE GIVE INTO
NANCY PELOSI?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
TOO SOON TO TELL.
I WANT TO TAKE ALL THESE ISSUES
SEPARATELY.
NUMBER ONE.
>> Dana: PUT THEM ALTOGETHER.
>> Greg: NUMBER ONE, WE THINK
IT'S BIG NEWS BECAUSE THE REALLY
BIG NEWS ISN'T HAPPENING.
WHICH MEANS THE COUNTRY IS IN
PRETTY GOOD CONDITION.
LOW CRIME, OPTIMISM.
WE HAVE THESE LITTLE THINGS.
THE REASON WHY IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRUMP IS BECAUSE THE MEDIA MAKES
IT ALL ABOUT TRUMP.
IT'S A SELF-FULFILLING PROPHECY.
IF THERE WAS NO TRUMP, GOD HELP
US ALL.
WHAT WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT?
PRISON REFORM.
I GET THE SENSE THIS IS A MISSED
CONGENIALITY AWARD.
FINALLY SOMETHING GOOD.
I HAVE MIXED FEELINGS ABOUT IT.
WE ARE INTO OUR FOURTH DECADE OF
DECLINE IN VIOLENT CRIME.
THIS IS THE SAFEST SOCIETY KNOWN
TO MANKIND.
CAN TO REFORM SOMETHING THAT IS
THEY SUCCESSFUL?
I READ THE REFORMS.
THINK THEY ARE FAIRLY MODERATE.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING, IT'S
AFFECTING 10% OF THE PRISON
POPULATION.
IT'S FOCUSING ON A PORTION OF
THAT.
THERE'S 2500 OTHER PRISONERS
THAT CAN APPLY FOR SOME KIND OF
EARLY RELEASE.
IT'S FAIRLY SMALL STEPS.
THE KEY IS THE TRAINING.
TO GET INMATES TO LEARN
SOMETHING.
SO WHEN I GET OUT OF BRIDGE AND
THEY DON'T END UP BACK IN
PRISON.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE TO THIS.
THAT'S THE POSITIVE PART.
MY OVERALL OBSERVATION ON THIS,
YOU GOT CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
YOU'VE GOT ACTUAL GUN CONTROL.
HE BANNED BUMP STOCKS.
PULLING OUT OF SYRIA, THE
DEFICIT KEEPS GROWING.
I'M PRETTY SURE WE HAVE A
PROGRESSIVE IN OFFICE.
WE SAID HE'S PREGNANT IS.
YOU CAN'T GUESS WHICH WAY HE'S
GOING TO GO.
HE'S NOT     NOT AN IDEOLOGUE.
IT'S WEIRD TO THE DEMOCRATS NOT
COOPERATING WITH HIS GUY WHEN HE
DID PRISON REFORM.
RIGHT?
HE'S PULLING OUT OF SYRIA.
HE WANTS THE WALL.
WHAT WILL HE GIVE YOU?
HE WILL GIVE YOU WHAT YOU WANT.
IT'S ABOUT BEING OBSTRUCTIONIST.
THAT'S THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Juan: ARE YOU KIDDING?
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
OBSTRUCTIONISTS?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Jedidiah: I THINK HE PROVES
HE'S WILLING TO REACH ACROSS THE
AISLE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO HIM
CAMPAIGNING, BACK IN THE DAY,
THIS IS THE STUFF HE WAS SAYING.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO PAINT HIM AS
AN EXTREMIST WHEN IT COMES THE
ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION IS REALLY
HARD ON THE WALL AND SECURING
THE BORDER BUT ON OTHER
ISSUES --
>> Juan: I THOUGHT HE SAID HE
WAS GOING TO GET RID OF THE
DEFICIT WHICH HAS SKYROCKETED.
>> Pete: THE HOUSE FREEDOM
CAUCUS WILL SAY NO DEAL ON THE
WALL IS A BAD DEAL FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE DEFICIT
AND REPUBLICANS COMPLAINING --
>> Dana: THEY DID THAT TO
GEORGE BUSH.
WHICHEVER PRESIDENT IS IN POWER,
THE OUT PARTY.
>> Greg: I THINK THE OLD NEWS
IS YOU RUN TO THE RIGHT, GOVERN
IN THE MIDDLE.
WENT AND RAN ON THE LEFT AND
GOVERN IN THE MIDDLE.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> Pete: THE SYRIA ONE IS A
BIG ONE.
KEEP YOUR EYES ON THAT.
>> Greg: IT JUST MAY BE THAT
HE WAS LIKE THIS WITH IRAQ.
HE IS STINGY ABOUT AMERICAN